I'd like to do some calculations in the
hopes that we'll come to some
realizations my mind is not what it used
to be that certainly isn't news to me
but I want to know how my life was spent
now that
I am near the end so add subtract
multiply and divide and I'll try and
figure out what I did with my life
has been 27 years in my bed
and there's not much that I would have
preferred to do instead it's been two
years two and six months one and I'm
sure you're curious honest three years
ago and I spent 45 years working for a
guy that I wanted to kill when I didn't
want it time that I've been 57 years
loving you my friends so I guess it all
makes sense at the end
[Music]
I spent nearly a full year master bed
and second only to the one we spent
copulating
you're not a fan of this vulgarity
but completeness is important for for
clarity I spent more than seven years
watching television and how could I not
regret that decision but I don't think
that I'll ever know how much time I did
or didn't spend looking in here
I spent 27 years in my bed and there's
not much that I would have preferred to
do instead I spent two years two and six
months one and I'm sure you're curious
almost three years gone I spent 25 years
working for a guy that I wanted to kill
when I didn't wanna
I've been 57 years loving you my friends
so I guess it all makes sense at the end
I've never known anyway but numbers and
some to understand what we are and what
we have become
but like numbers the perfect that's how
this has been for me and I wanted us to
give you everything you need 80 years a
Lavin for eating food stop reading books
in 57 with you two
knows one small one life it somehow is a
never quite enough time
I spent 27 years in my bed and there's
nothing much that I would have preferred
to do instead I spent two years June and
six months one and I'm sure you carry as
long as three years but I've been 25
years working for a guy that I wanted to
kill when I didn't want to divert that's
been 57 years loving you my friends so I
guess it all makes sense at the end or I
guess it all makes sense at the end
yeah gasp it all makes sense at the end
you